[Applause]
across the uk
including london edinburgh
cardiff northern ireland on royal naval
ships at sea
and gibraltar ii a special gun salute
for prince philip
once a minute 41 times
a tribute to from his son prince charles
my dear papa was a was a very special
person who
i think above all else would have been
amazed by the reaction
and the touching things that have been
said about him
and from that point of view we are my
family deeply grateful
for all that it will sustain us in this
particular loss and at this particularly
sad time
outside the queen's london residence a
growing row of flowers from the public
for the man who stood beside her for 73
years of marriage
it's a reminder for us of you know those
wonderful values of
bravery and loyalty and he was
just a great british man someone who
gives that many years to
public service it's just come down and
i mean it's a sad moment isn't it well
meaning that something the royal family
is trying to discourage
because of covid restrictions buckingham
palace is keen to avoid the royal
residences turning into a focus of mass
mourning it's actually asked people
not to come down here and lay flowers
but as you can see
there is a steady stream of people
who've turned up to pay their respects
anyway
the pandemic has also drastically scaled
down plans for how he'll be laid to rest
philip himself had ruled out a state
funeral buckingham palace has announced
a service at windsor castle on april the
17th
is to have no public access or public
procession beforehand
as per the uk's pandemic regulations the
number of mourners will be limited to
30.
prince harry who's distanced himself
from the royal family will return from
his new home in the u.s for it
but his pregnant wife meghan markle will
not on the advice of her doctor
rory challenge al jazeera london